Now the first thing to notice is that all
of these are read and write accesses. There's nothing special
about them. This is, this is going to be modifying
data using loads and stores, and this is storing a
value into it, and this is reading a value and
using a value. So all of these are normal read
write accesses, but there is a difference between. The way
the program uses this flag variable versus this data structure.
The flag variable is being used as a synchronization
variable. And that's a, a secret that only this P1
and P2 know about. That this, even though innocuously
it looks like a simple Integer variable that is used
in a program where there is special semantic for
this particular variable so far as this, this program is
concerned. P1 and P2 know that this is the way
by which their signalling each other, that something that this
guy waiting on is available from P1.
Right? And so its a synchronization variable. On
the other hand, the - The data structure A is a normal data. But, both accessing
the synchronization variable and normal data is being
accomplished by simple read write accesses that's available
in the processor. And that's how we're able
to get the solution for this particular question.
It's comforting to know that atomic read and
write operations are good for doing simple co-ordination
among processes as we illustrate it through this
question. And in fact, when we look at
certain implementation of barrier algorithms later on You'll
find that this is all that is needed
from the architecture in order to implement some
of them. But now, how about implementing a synchronization
primitive like a mutual-exclusion lock? Are atomic reads and writes sufficient
to implement a synchronization primitive like
a mutual-exclusion lock? Let's investigate that.